[Music]
got the world's biggest tablets
oh good mommy you're here come help it's
a big what are you doing
Claire was together what are you doing
just checking how much weight I lost
ever dance class the last time I checked
myself on the scale I weighed like 175
but I haven't been eating that good
because of all the stress I've been
underneath so hopefully I'm not over 180
I'm panicking out I mean I'm up to 184
so I'm really hoping I'm gonna be able
to fit in these size 12 dresses tomorrow
when we go dress shopping with Jay Jay
Oh
Ilana I need to lose some pounds before
the pageant we do some more exercises
besides dancing we need to make sure
that we are tip-top shape for the
pageant and that cat needs a break
all right you put a pole by yourself
what do you have in mind I've been
watching these skinny [ __ ] do it late
night and it's been working for them so
I think you're definitely work for us
right they never wanted firmer shows
they tell the truth all the time if it's
on TV news on the Internet is true
Oh Kate you feel the barn you're working
mom I'm working mama first you had me on
the trash bags oh now you got me
strapped up in a vibrator uh that's not
a vibrator all right
ah see see how fun it is to be able to
work out and not have to move see I
didn't see you and be talking to you and
still do this you both at the same time
you're working out your abs and your leg
you're gonna be dancing with your leg
and you got to show your belly to the
judges why are you laughing about this
because you look ridiculous doing that
Claudia de bourree come exhausted
[Music]